let's start with the baltimore ravens
more positive tests for the organization
it's not just players there were
reportedly four more positives today but
only one player placed on the covet 19
reserve list as linebacker pernell
mcphee it sounds like he was a positive
although we can't assume anything they
never say whether or not a guy was a
positive it gets reported by someone or
it doesn't you just have to wait to see
whether or not he comes off or whether
or not there's a report that he was
positive if he's positive he won't be
playing on thursday night if he's
just close contact with someone who's
positive he's got 48 hours to get to the
point where he can return and it's a
five-day window from when you were
exposed now if he was exposed to
somebody on sunday and that's when this
all started with a couple of running
backs who tested positive he won't be
back in time for thursday so my guess
would be no mcphee we already know no
j.k dobbins no mark ingram no brandon
williams if he was exposed to dobbins or
ingram on sunday and more importantly
for the ravens no practice today
everything was conducted virtually on
the most important practice day on a
short week because monday you don't do
anything wednesday's a walk through
tuesday is your workday their workday
was spent at home communicating via
their computers sheree
yeah they're co-depleted mike going into
this game and they already faced an
uphill battle to stay in this race to
beat the steelers which they need to do
to stay in at least the division race
which i think is a long shot at this
point but
uh who knows how many players are going
to end up with we do expect there to be
more players added to the list before
thursday night that won't play in that
game so we'll see the numbers that they
have they're already down at running
back they're gonna have to call up a
practice squad player at running back to
have even three running backs assuming
that none of the other running backs are
going on the list if they are then
they're really going to be hard up at
running back and you may see lamar
jackson be their entire running game uh
on thursday night but it this is this is
difficult for the ravens there's no
question about that we've seen a couple
this year mike where teams have had all
these coveted cases and it's been very
difficult on them this is one of the
toughest i've seen that they're gonna
have to make do uh with what they have
and without the players on the coveted
list
yeah i don't even know that smashing
watermelons would work for john harbaugh
on wednesday night before they go to
pittsburgh to take on the steelers
and
the other reality here is they are still
in the window where there could be
additional positives because of the
incubation period those are the two
doughnut holes the nfl's been wrestling
with all year the incubation period of
up to five to seven days between
exposure and
generation of a positive test if you do
have enough exposure to actually come
down with the disease and that lag
between sample collection and result
generation which is what stung them on
sunday with the positive samples given
by ingram and dobbins and then finding
out that they were around their
teammates all day long while they were
shedding virus that is the thing that
can continue to cause problems and
that's why they're operating remotely
because somebody could
end up testing positive today so by
staying home that person who ultimately
we find out tomorrow tested positive
today wasn't in a position to shed virus
over others and potentially make the
situation worse the nfl is monitoring
the developments and has indicated that
the game is still on and why is the game
still on why didn't they move it to
sunday or monday or tuesday because and
and let's face it there is a commitment
to stage a game that will be televised
on thursday night on nbc and there will
be between 20 and 25 million people who
watch it because it's a captive audience
it's the best game of the day and the
nfl doesn't want to give that up and
there's no no guarantee shireen that if
they move it to sunday or monday or
tuesday
that it'll be any better so they've
decided week seven bucks raiders strike
while the iron is hot get the game
played don't delay because you may not
get the game in at all if you decide to
just wait by a couple of days so next
man up go sign somebody if you have to
let's go you see the problem is because
of that that
waiting period
on the front end i it's not as easy to
sign somebody you better have your
practice squad ready or or you're you're
you're stuck that's it you you better
have your your warm bodies you better be
thinking about who on defense could
maybe play running back if need be i
mean this may be old-school two-way
football before it's all said and done
but the nfl is going to expect teams to
show up to be ready no matter who's on
that coven 19 reserve list and i don't
know what the number is of a critical
mass that would get the nfl to pull the
plug i don't think the nfl wants to find
out and i think the nfl is going to
resist saying okay that's it we're going
to give you a a pass here we're going to
delay the game until week 18 or whatever
i think they're going to resist that as
long as they possibly can sharing
yeah i've asked that a couple times mike
on the conference calls that that we've
had with the nfl and and they won't
answer that question but you know they
have numbers i mean colleges all have
those numbers
and there is a number out there and
obviously you have to have a quarterback
to play and there are certain positions
you have to have a certain number of
offensive linemen a certain number of
defensive line to play i think offensive
line and quarterback are the the key
positions that you need i don't think
they're going to worry about if the
ravens don't have any running backs hey
put rg3 out there put lamar jackson out
there running back and and go and and
simple facts are mike
i i think maybe if they could have moved
a game into that spot they would have
but look they're not going to give up
thanksgiving day games they're the
highest rated games almost annually uh
for the for the networks they just are
people watch i mean that what else do
you have to do on thanksgiving day
except eat and watch football and so
that's what people do and the ratings
are extremely high for those games the
cowboys game almost always ranks number
one in regular season games
based on ratings and so they can't move
a game from sunday to thursday that's
impossible they want to get that game in
and have those high ratings for all
three of those games
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports